[Musica]
7 luglio 2019
arrestate faceva faceva caldo tanto
caldo
e io ero su un treno regionale in piedi
senza re condizionata e con due enormi
valigie e in tutto ciò il viaggio che
sarebbe dovuto durare meno di sei ore
però oltre 12
immagino che ti starai chiedendo perché
chi te l'ha fatto fare
una settimana prima
ricevetti una chiamata
anzi la chiamata quella che aspetti da
tanto tempo e che magari fatto tanto per
ricevere
in tempo zero presi la decisione di
trasferirmi dalle marche a milano per
sfruttare un'opportunità professionale
e soprattutto in questa avventura
avevo capito di poter contare su una
grande alleata la mia convinzione che
dipendesse da me più di quanto credessi
questo infatti mi ha permesso di
raggiungere obiettivi anche migliori di
quelle che avevo pianificato
obiettivi che per me sono come la
bussola per i marinai e
seneca disse non esiste vento favorevole
per il marinaio che non sa dove andare
e quando sei in mare di certo non puoi
controllare il vento e le onde devi
concentrarti sul manovra è la barca il
meglio possibile per poter comunque
arrivare alla meta desiderata
rifletti momento
quante volte hai dato eccessivo peso ad
aspetti che non potevi che non potevi
controllare anziché concentrarti su ciò
che più fare
la scelta dipende date
palanti obiettivi ho sempre avuto il
sogno di fondare di gestire un'impresa
1 perchè
sognavo di diventare indipendente non
voglio dipendere da nessuno ma
soprattutto perché volevo creare
qualcosa qualcosa di mio e oggi
nonostante non sia ancora arrivato anzi
all'età di 24 anni ho gia ha fondato
insieme ad altri diverse imprese a cui
partecipo attivamente nella gestione
e tutto questo grazie
a un obiettivo
e soprattutto ricordo che all'età di 20
anni vivevano un paesino di mila
abitanti e
non vedevo come poter diventare un
domani un domani imprenditore studiavo
all'università ogni tanto lavoravo come
muratore insieme a mio padre
e sentivo di aver capito che per
raggiungere questo mio obiettivo mi
mancava qualcosa anzi forse qualcuno
perché a quell'età di certo non avevo le
conoscenze e le competenze giuste
e sentivo di aver bisogno di qualcuno
che in qualche modo ce l'avesse fatta
che mi facesse da maestro da mentore
e sentivo che per trovarlo dipendeva da
me e da lezione e avrei fatto da quel
giorno in poi
c'è messi parecchio tempo ma alla fine
ricevette la chiamata di cui ti ho
parlato
ed i mentori in realtà nei travagli ne
trovai ben due
ora riflette il momento
quante volte hai aspettato perché ti
sentivi vittima della situazione
anziché agire facendo il possibile
la scena dipende solo da te
in una serie mi trasferii
e ricordo quella settimana ancora oggi
lunedì 1º luglio ricevette la chiamata e
accettare la proposta di trasferimenti
lano martedì e lo dissi e alla mia
fidanzata dell'epoca
mercoledì e ne parlai con i miei
genitori con i quali litiga gli come mai
abbiamo fatto prima d'ora giovedì
venerdì facciamo pace diedi l'ultimo
esame all'università e domenica presi il
comodissimo regionale di quelle di cui
ho parlato
il mio lavoro consisteva in realtà con
sistema oggi nel trovare nuovi clienti
grazie alle strategie di web marketing è
un argomento che in qualche modo mi ha
sempre appassionato e credo che abbia
cambiato il mondo del lavoro soprattutto
bosco vita
e io
partito quasi da zero in pochissimi mesi
riuscì ad ottenere un ruolo fondamentale
nella divisione marketing
dell'azienda con il quale collaboravo
ottenendo anche importanti
responsabilità
però sai non avevo
non è stato non è stato tutto rose e
fiori anzi ho commesso diversi errori
diverse volte ho dubitato di farcela e
soprattutto sentivo il peso crescente
delle responsabilità del resto avevo
solo vent'anni e non avevo il pieno
controllo delle otto volante su chi ero
salito
ma potevo decidere su cosa concentrarmi
potevo decidere se
rendermi o provare c'è un'altra volta
potevo decidere se andare a dormire o
rimanere sveglio per studiare potevo
decidere se disinteressarmi o chiedere
aiuto
rifletti momento
quante volte
trasportare dai tuoi stati d'animo
anziché ricordarti che puoi
gestirli e ottenere un sultato migliore
la scelta dipende solo da te
ora immagina la mia emozione quando
l'azienda per il quale collaboravo nel
2020 è stata invitata al fa nella chi
live uno degli eventi di web marketing
più importante al mondo l 1 chiamato
perché per ritirare un premio riservato
a chi supera i 10 milioni di fatturato
grazie a un particolare strumento
e io ero partito poco pochi mesi prima
da da un paesino di mila abitanti
ero con ero nella stessa stanza con il
idoli per i miei idoli di quando avevo
mosso i primi passi web marketing
russell brunson anthony robbins
gareth white rai a noi dei e gli orali
ero lì con loro
e tutto questo grazie a un obiettivo ad
avere lavorato duramente
e soprattutto l'aver creduto di poter
influenzare le cose più di quanto
credessi
rifletti momento
quante volte si è fatto sopraffare da
pensieri negativi
anziché dare spazio all'ottimismo
la scelta dipende date
ora ora sono solo l'imprenditore
gestisco diversi clienti e soprattutto
sono diventato indipendente
e credo che nulla sarebbe accaduto se
non avessi capito quanto le cose
dipendessero da me e da lezioni che
avrei fatto
molto probabilmente non avesse pensato
così oggi non sarei su questo palco non
avrei conosciuto determinate persone a
me oggi molto importanti
e soprattutto credo che molto
probabilmente
sarei come tanti altri a lamentarmi di
politica l'economia e che il mondo non è
più quello di una volta
per come la vedo io la scelta per il tuo
futuro dipende tra
pensare di essere in balia degli eventi
come una zanzara in una tempesta
oppure decidere oggi di essere al cento
per cento causa dei suoi risultati
nonostante le circostanze
io c'ero seconda e lo rifarei mille
volte
e tu che strada vuoi prendere
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]